- [Stephen] Perhaps because I realized
I might not have much time,
I renewed my efforts to tackle
the big question in
cosmology in the early '60s.
I have been very lucky that my disability
has not been a serious handicap.
I faced a life unable
to properly communicate.
All hopes of finishing my book,
and perhaps even my
career, seemed to be over.
- He's an English physicist, author,
and professor at the
University of Cambridge.
He has a rare form of ALS that
has gradually paralyzed him
over the past few decades.
He hasn't let that stop him though
and he's become a bestselling author,
and one of the greatest
scientists of our generation.
He's Stephen Hawking,
and here's my take on his
top 10 rules for success.
Rule number one is my personal favorite.
Make sure to stick around
all the way to the end
for a special bonus clip.
Also when Stephen's talking,
if he says something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below,
and put quotes around it,
so other people can be inspired as well.
Enjoy.
(elegant music)
- [Stephen] The decline in my health
was a stark reminder,
that time was against me.
Yet despite the pressures in my family,
I was determined to realize
a lifelong ambition,
by writing a popular book about
how the universe had begun.
I wanted the book to be
read by millions of people
around the world, like a
bestselling airport novel.
- I did not think it would work.
I did not think it would work,
because basically if you look
at all the other books in airports,
there are none like that.
- [Stephen] However, I felt sure that
the mass market would want to know
about how the universe began.
By 1984, I had completed
the first chapter.
I signed up with Peter,
and set to work completing
the first draft of my book.
I tried to simplify the
physics as best I could
and by the end I was pleased,
and felt it was in pretty good shape,
but Peter wasn't convinced.
- I was pretty disappointed.
Yeah, I thought this is
going to be really difficult.
- [Stephen] Lightning, did indeed strike,
but not in the way that
Peter and I were hoping.
That summer I had taken
a break from rewriting
to travel to Switzerland on holiday,
but while I was there I
caught a chest infection,
that developed into pneumonia,
and quickly became very serious.
I was put into a drug induced coma,
and on to a life support machine.
The doctors thought I was so far gone,
they offered to Jane to
turn off the machine,
but she refused.
Finally, Jane insisted that I
was flown back to Cambridge.
The weeks of intensive care
were the darkest of my life.
I felt I had always
fought my illness so hard,
that I was not prepared
to give in so easily.
Slowly the drugs began to work,
and the infection passed,
but the surgeons had to
perform a tracheotomy,
to allow me to breathe which made
a small incision in my windpipe,
and connected me to a ventilator
via the hole in my throat.
As a result, I was now robbed
of the ability to talk.
I faced a life unable
to properly communicate.
All hopes of finishing my book
and perhaps even my
career, seemed to be over.
I had enough movement in my right hand
to be able to click the computer system
and write the words I wanted.
Finally, I was free to communicate again.
I was keen to make up the lost time
that my illness had forced upon me.
I had a stack of notes from Peter Guzzardi
suggesting changes and
clarifications to my book,
but I needed practical help
with the rewrite at my end.
Someone who could act as a go between.
- [Man] This is keeping the graphic
as simple as we can.
- [Stephen] After months of
work the rewrite was complete.
None of us really knew whether the book
would be liked and would
sell as we all hoped for.
All we could do now was give it a title,
A Brief History of Time,
send it off to the printers, and wait.
(exciting music)
But to everyone's surprise,
the book sold copy after copy,
and very quickly bookshops
were selling out.
- When it hit the bestseller list,
you're obviously surprised.
It was a pleasant surprise,
and it certainly was a surprise.
I don't think you'll find
anybody, maybe I'm wrong,
who will say oh yes, we knew all along,
this was going to be a major hit.
- I had no expectation that it would
be the number one bestselling
book in the world.
Not just here, but Germany,
Slovenia, France, Italy,
everywhere in the world
there was the hope,
that someone had found
the mystery of life.
- From then on, it was just a race
to keep the book in print,
and marching towards
a million copies sold.
- It was very gratifying.
In the 38 years that I've
been in this business,
I don't think I've ever had a book
that's stayed at the top of
the bestseller list that long.
- I was amazed at how well it did.
I think it worked.
He inspired people.
He gave people some overall sense
of the birth of the universe.
It made this subject become
a subject of conversation
among people in all walks of life.
- [Woman] Professor Stephen Hawking's book
A Brief History of Time,
an unlikely but successful
publishing phenomena.
- [Man] A Brief history of Time has sold
about eight million copies.
- [Man] A popular book about his theories
is already topping the
American bestsellers list.
- [Woman] The hugely successful,
A Brief History of Time,
by Stephen Hawking.
- [Stephen] A Brief History of Time
stayed on the bestseller
list for over four years
and entered into the Guinness
Book of Records for doing so.
To date, over 10 million copies
have been sold worldwide.
Over the next few years a lot of fuss
was made about my book.
I became famous nationally
and around the world,
as it was translated into
40 different languages.
If one is disabled, one should concentrate
on the things one can do,
and not regret the things one can't do.
- Given how hard it is
for you to communicate.
You mentioned in the film, how sometimes,
when people are chatting,
your thoughts drift off into
things like how the universe began.
Do you think in some ways your disability
has made you a better scientist?
- [Stephen] I must admit I do tend
to drift off to thinking
about physics or black holes
when I get left behind
in the conversation.
In fact, my disability
has been a help in a way.
It has freed me from teaching
or sitting on boring committees,
and given me more time
to think and do research.
Theoretical physics is
one of the few fields
in which being disabled is no handicap.
It's all in the mind.
Falling in love and getting engaged
was the motivation that I needed.
If I were to get married,
I had to get a job,
and to get a job I had to finish my PhD.
I therefore started working hard
for the first time in my life.
To my surprise, I found I liked it.
Perhaps because I realized
I might not have much time,
I renewed my efforts to tackle the
big question in cosmology
in the early '60s.
Did the universe have a beginning or not?
Having lived on this wonderful planet
for over 71 years, I feel
my proudest achievement
has been to inspire people to think
about the cosmos and our place in it.
Since I believe there is no afterlife,
I think it's important to realize
we only have a very short time alive,
and should make the best of it.
All my life I have sought
to understand the universe
and find answers to these questions.
I have been very lucky that my disability
has not been a serious handicap.
Indeed, it has probably given me more time
than most people to pursue
the quest for knowledge.
As a small boy I used
to take things apart.
I wanted to find out how they worked.
That is still what I want,
but I've moved on to bigger
things, like the universe.
The thrill of discovering something
no one knew before, is
like nothing else I know.
I want to share my
excitement with everyone.
My main challenge has been
Lou Gehrig's disease, or ALS.
I have had it since I was 21,
but it has not prevented me from exploring
the universe with my mind,
or having three wonderful children.
I have lived over two thirds of my life,
with the threat of death hanging over me.
Because every new day could be my last,
I have developed a desire to make
the most of each and every minute.
Although I'm 71 now, I
still go to work every day
at Cambridge University.
- I'll see you in a bit.
Going shopping.
- [Stephen] Keeping an active mind
has been vital to my survival.
As has been maintaining a sense of humor.
- [Man] You clearly have a
very good sense of humor.
Many will remember your
appearance in the Simpsons.
- [Crowd] Stephen Hawking!
- The world's smartest man.
- [Stephen] I'm probably better known
for my appearances on The Simpson's,
and The Big Bang Theory,
than I am for my scientific discoveries.
I've made a cameo appearance on Star Trek,
my favorite Sci-fi show.
- You are bluffing.
- [Stephen] Wrong again, Albert.
I find humor and a few jokes
are a great help in a lecture
on the mysteries of the universe.
(elegant music)
Ever since the dawn of civilization,
people have craved for an understanding
of the underlying order of the world.
There ought to be something very special
about the renditions of the universe.
What can be more special,
than that there is no boundary?
There should be no
boundary to human endeavor.
The Olympic games are
all about transforming
our perception of the world.
We are all different.
There is no such thing as a standard
or run of the mill human being,
but we share the same human spirit.
However difficult life may seem,
there is always something
you can do and succeed at.
I feel a sense of achievement that
I have managed to make
these contributions,
despite having ALS.
I have not allowed my disability
to stop me doing most things.
My motto is there are no boundaries.
Thank you.
(audience applause)
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
parijatprakash asked me to.
If there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below,
and I'll see what I can do.
I'm also curious to figure out
what did Stephen say that had
the biggest and most
profound impact on you?
What are you going to immediately apply
to your life, or to your business?
Leave it in the comments.
I'm going to join in the discussion.
Finally, I want to give a
quick shout out to Ola "Tux'.
Thank you so much for hosting me
on your YouTube channel and your podcast
to talk about my book Your One Word.
It was a blast. I really appreciate it,
and thank you for all the love
that you are showing entrepreneurs.
- When you look at the title,
it's so mild, and so straightforward,
that you expect to read, okay I get it.
He's going to talk about just one word.
- Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
- [Stephen] Here are the most
important pieces of advice
that I've passed on to my children.
One, remember to look up at the stars
and not down at your feet.
Two, never give up work.
Work gives you meaning and purpose,
and life is empty without it.
- It's beautiful advice.
- [Stephen] Three, if you
are lucky enough to find love
remember it is rare,
and don't throw it away.